true horror the airplane door belching
smoke and a burning red light the dead
talking in ancient guttural Latin a
monstrous Angel made of rings wings and
eyes whipping barbs tentacles at
screaming terrified priests you can
scarcely imagine a more hellish Place
Bishop Franklin's knees gave out under
him as soon as the man set foot back on
Solid Ground nearing his 70th birthday
he'd never been a particularly tough man
but after the day he'd had he doubted
he'd ever be the same again almost being
whipped into another dimension almost
being at the center of a nuclear
explosion seeing you throw up on the
ground as the foundation Personnel
rushed over to him never never again
just eight hours earlier Bishop Franklin
had been getting on with his Friday
preparations they had Mass coming up
this weekend so he was doing the rounds
of the cathedral putting out new candles
and straightening pews he was nearly
done ready to get on with the rest of
his morning when he saw two suited
figures entering the cathedral he
shuffled over to them trying to explain
that they were closed but quickly
faltered when he saw the grave look on
their faces just 10 minutes later he was
in the back of their car still holding a
spare candle with Agents from the SCP
Foundation sitting on either side of him
they handed him file after file each
most redacted explaining the basis of
who they were and where they were headed
it was a lot for the old priest to wrap
his head around he'd always believed in
a higher power and a spiritual realm but
this sounded a whole lot more serious
than that monsters aliens other
dimensions facilities portals he
questioned the agents on it they just
look grimly from one to another as the
car wound its way to the private
airstrip in the middle of nowhere
no Bishop Franklin had always hated
flying but he hated it a whole lot more
as he approached the airplane with no
idea where he'd be landing a small group
of men were gathered on the runway just
by the foot of a Boeing aircraft it
seemed like a pretty substantial plane
for such a small group of them he was at
least a little heartened to see that
none of them had brought luggage either
in fact most of them were just like him
as Bishop Franklin approached the group
he recognized various faces other
Bishops archbishops and Senior priests
with him there they totaled seven the
others all looked at him not saying much
Bishop Franklin tried his best to start
asking questions but two things happened
in quick succession that closed his
mouth very quickly firstly the luggage
hold of the plane was opened and two
enormous shapes were loaded into it via
forklift each shape had unmistakable
symbols on the sheets covering them
nuclear danger reeling from this
Revelation Bishop Franklin turned to the
group to be face to face with the Pope
himself he immediately shut his mouth
you may also be wondering what on Earth
was going on at this Airfield the truth
is Bishop Franklin along with six other
Priests of abrahamic faiths were about
to embark on the monthly flight of
scp-616 within this plane as all these
men were soon about to find out exists
an emergency door covered with satanic
iconography this door when opened at
ground level operates just like any
other emergency door leading to the
outside of the plane although any
individuals who had passed through this
door in this normal State reported
feeling heightened anxiety during and
after however once a month this door
will be anything but normal opening a
gate to well you'll soon see in order to
mitigate the threat posed to humanity
through
scp-616-1 or the gate the plane must be
in the air at the time of its open
opening far above and away from any
human settlements in order to keep this
event contained the door must be kept
open for the duration of the Portal's
existence until it has closed of its own
accord but holding this door open is not
a simple test of strength it is a test
of belief in order to protect all of
humanity from unknown horrors of a
cataclysmic scale seven Priests of
abrahamic Fates must be on board for
this monthly flight praying for the door
to remain open the ability to keep the
door open it turns out is unrelated to
physical prowess but instead is based
entirely on one's own belief that the
door can be held open as such religious
figures praying to a higher power are
incredibly well suited to the task once
per year the flight is blessed by the
pope and every time the plane takes off
it must be holding two nuclear warheads
in its Hull both can be remotely
detonated by the ground team who will be
in constant radio community location
with the pilot should the pilot fail to
give them regular updates on the status
of
scp-616-1 the event will be treated as
an XK Class end of the world scenario in
both nuclear devices will be detonated
without hesitation but Bishop Franklin
only knew about half of this information
from his redacted set of documents and
had forgotten half of them on his
stressful car Journey as he strapped
himself into a window seat he was
trembling like a leaf he desperately
wanted to complain about being put into
the situation but he wasn't entirely
sure who he would complain to if he
spoke to anyone external about what he
was about to witness he had been told by
the foundation agents that he would be
administered with a Class C amnestic
whatever that meant he really didn't
want to find out fortunately for him the
most familiar of the faces from the
group of priests sat next to him in the
aisle seat Bishop what was his name
sensing Bishop Franklin's on uncertainty
the man reached a hand over and warmly
reintroduced himself Bishop Pete they'd
met two years ago in Berlin just that
small action was almost enough to settle
Bishop Franklin's nerves as the plane
started to barrel down the runway almost
the plane took off causing the old man's
stomach to drop heart hammering he
looked around spotting the emergency
door it was just up ahead of him around
the middle of the fuselage it would have
looked like a normal emergency exit but
for the blood red markings scrawled
across it a wave of dread washed over
him it certainly looked evil that was
for sure trying his best to help Bishop
Pete struck up a conversation he
explained it wasn't his first time doing
this he'd been drafted to help three
months ago it was scary for sure but
everything was totally fine the
foundation had planned everything to a t
it would have helped Bishop Franklin's
nerves but it only made his mind jump to
the nuclear weapons he'd seen low loaded
into where his suitcase would have
normally gone the two of them lapsed
into silence for a while no one on the
plane was really speaking he supposed he
should have used this opportunity to
pray but according to his briefing he'd
be doing a lot of that very soon he
hadn't entirely understood what the
foundation had meant by that he'd been
told to pray to quote keep the door open
what had they meant by that a bang
shattered the silence as the emergency
door slammed wide open in an instant the
plane went into a nosedive as all the
air rushed from inside the lights went
out for several seconds then came back
on in flashing panicked spasms Bishop
Franklin clung for dear life onto the
back of the chair in front of him as the
Roar of air rushed around him it had
gone dark outside with shapeless clouds
swirling around him shaking the plane
screaming voices filled the aircraft not
just the voices of the men on board but
women and children too crying out in
agony and Terror through throats that
sounded like they'd been lashed with
razor wire then he saw it
scp-616-1 the gate was wide open smoke
billowed out of it crawling along the
floors of the cabin like an octopus
creeping its way along the ocean floor
red lights seemed to spill out of it but
when he tried to look through the gate
itself it was like his brain wasn't
working anymore there were colors there
but there were ones he didn't recognize
maybe they weren't colors at all it was
like his brain fixated on trying to sort
them into something that made sense
something rational a hand grasped his
arm and he turned to Sea Bishop Pete
staring at him with wild eyes the plane
was going down they could both feel it
and that emergency door was slowly
creeping shut they had been brought onto
this plane for one job only to pray like
their lives depended on it Bishop
Franklin screwed his eyes shut and
clasped His Hands Together Yen prayed
like that since he was a little kid but
he figured now was the time to use all
the tricks in the book he begged and
pleaded in a tiny voice for God to keep
that door open it felt so
counter-intuitive so backwards to want
to keep that kind of door open as the
air roared and screamed around him but a
small voice inside of him told him to
persevere have a little faith but
suddenly the bishop noticed that the man
sitting alongside him had fallen silent
feeling like a naughty child at Mass he
opened one eye and peered sideways
Bishop Pete was still in his seat but
he'd slumped over he wasn't breathing
his skin was cold to the touch deathly
cold then all of a sudden his head
rocket backwards and he started talking
not talking like a normal man but
talking like a man possessed his dead
eyes rolled around in his head aimlessly
as guttural voices rasped out of his
throat none of them were the words that
Bishop Franklin recognized they sounded
almost like Latin but far darker and
more ancient and the more the dead man
spoke the more the emergency door
the bishop started praying again much
harder this time digging his fingernails
into his palm so hard that he felt them
drawing blood he needed to keep this
door open he had to but he could he
believed it entirely in that moment the
door banged back open wider than ever
despite the chanting of the dead body in
the seat next to him nightmare swelled
to the Forefront of his mind as the
plane hurtled to the ground only the
plane wasn't hurtling to the ground in
fact it was flying at a perfectly steady
altitude of 10 972 meters with an
airspeed of about 780 kilometers an hour
in fact aside from the death of Bishop
Pete everything within the plane was
going perfectly to plan deaths of
priests were just an occupational hazard
of keeping this SCP contained the pilot
at the front of the plane regarded the
whole situation playing out behind him
while feeding constant information back
to base everything was going perfectly
according to plan until the angel
Bishop Franklin wasn't the first one to
see it that was the unfortunate lot of
Archbishop Michael who was sitting
closest to the emergency door he first
spied it while staring through into the
void but his screams of Terror warning
those around him were drowned out by all
the other commotion it was only when the
angel's wings crept their way through
the edges of the door and the creature
LED itself into the cabin that the
others saw it but by this point it was
too late for Archbishop Michael the
angel was not like the angels we see in
pop culture a tall blonde person with
white robes fluffy wings and a gentle
face it was a shifting mass of eyes and
tortured Wings partially crawling along
the ground partially floating under the
weight of its massive frame it had to
squeeze itself through the door to fit
into the plane but as it did it lashed
out at the Archbishop with a sinewy
tendril and got to work violently
killing him that was when Bishop
Franklin sought and began to panic he
wanted nothing more than to stop praying
to let the emergency door slam shut and
keep this creature away from them but
that little voice inside his head told
him that wouldn't work if that door was
allowed to close before the gate had
then it would cause the apocalypse he
could not have that blood on his hands
so he prayed sweat pouring down his face
as the angel forced its way through the
gate and into the cabin he prayed as it
slumped across the aisles working its
way along the line of men slaughtering
them one by one he prayed as it saw him
and Rose to its full height unfurling
great wings and readying itself for the
kill and he prayed as a win more
powerful than any on Earth blew through
the cabin and pulled the angel back
through the gate the emergency door
slammed shut and in an instant the plane
seemed to ride itself no more turbulence
no more wind the light flickered once
more and then came back on steadily the
seat belt sign pinged off and oxygen
masks dropped from the ceiling about
four hours too late Bishop Franklin
couldn't believe the time when he looked
at his wristwatch he had been on this
plane for weeks surely not just four
hours that was absurd it all felt like a
dream as the aircraft circled around the
airstrip preparing for landing
everything in the plane seemed totally
normal to him now except of course for
the four dead bodies one of which was
slumped towards him in the aisle seat
the plane landed the bishop staggered
down the stairs and threw up on the
blacktop after a few awkward moments the
pilot sidled over to him and muttered a
quick thanks I was really close to
calling it a failure there and having to
set off them nukes I don't know what you
prayed for but you did good today Bishop
Franklin didn't feel like he did good he
felt like he'd had his whole life his
whole world view turned upside down in
the space of an interstate flight he had
been moments away from either being
vaporized by a nuclear bomb or from
having economy seats to the premiere of
the destruction of the World As We Knew
It but just 31 days later Bishop
Franklin was on that same flight again
praying his hardest as the aircraft
dropped into Free Fall if there was one
thing that the foundation noticed about
working with religious leaders it was
that they had a real determination to
keep coming back to help keep the world
safe but the foundation didn't have the
heart to tell them was that all of the
satanic markings on the door were
actually fake they had been added by
researchers in an attempt to make
scp-616-1 carry more significance for
those in the aircraft later testing
revealed that it was not exclusive to
abrahamic faiths or any faith groups for
that matter that they could keep the
gate open anyone who believed they could
do it was capable of it Faith leaders
however are still being utilized and the
blessing is still being performed by the
pope on a yearly basis it had been found
that these external rituals will will
not necessarily directly impactful have
strengthened the belief and resolve of
those inside the plane yielding fewer
casualties and shorter durations various
experiments have been conducted to see
beyond the Event Horizon of the gate to
see what's on the other side those in
the plane have reported as having the
name Paradise despite never going inside
a remote-controlled Rover was sent
inside the gate on one experiment but
the footage was deemed far too dangerous
as all those who witnessed it died
within two months hopefully you didn't
appear too closely into the gate as you
watched this video now check out the
plane that was never
scp-787 and scp-2086 man-eating bus for
more